hi
my name is Trevor Jones I'm gonna
developer programs engineer on the
Android team let's take a bit to talk
about how to do network service
discovery on Android so what is network
service discovery so say that you have a
game and you want to let friends play
with each other one approach is to get
email addresses for everyone in the game
and use that to set up a shared room on
a server somewhere in the cloud it's not
a bad approach especially if you're
going to be competing with someone far
away but if all your friends are sitting
right next to you
all those email addresses are going to
get a bit inconvenient wouldn't it be
great if you could just find nearby
users who also happen to have your app
just based on the physical proximity
this is where network service discovery
or NSD comes into the picture NSD lets
your app find other devices on the local
network that supports services you're
interested in those services could be
physical devices like printers webcams
HTTP servers and yes even games in a
sense it turns any local network into a
social network for apps take this game
here which uses NSD to place everyone on
the same subnet into a virtual waiting
room is a quick way to form teams once
discovered you'll then be able to
connect directly to any of those apps
using the standard Android networking
stack so let's go into a bit more
details about how all this works and
then I'll show you how to implement the
code for all this inside of your app NSD
is based on two protocols DNS SD and
multicast DNS the SD stands for service
discovery like DNS on the Internet this
provides the mapping between human
friendly host names
so same iPhone dot local and the IP
address where that device lives now
normally you'd go to something like
Google comm in this case everything is
going to be ending in something dot
local because it's on the local subnet
that's how the device can distinguish
between devices advertised via multicast
DNS and devices advertised using the
global DNS system so unlike traditional
DNS M DNS is completely distributed
which means no central server
devices communicate amongst themselves
to build a network directory of services
since it's based on multicast it only
works between devices on the same
broadcast domain so such as a LAN it
also requires the network supports
multicast traffic which some businesses
or University networks might disable but
it should work without problems on most
home networks or even small business
networks dns SD extends multicast dns to
provide service discovery listing what
hosts implement specific protocols many
people think of dns exclusively in the
context of mapping host names to IP
addresses but des is actually general
with somewhat limited hierarchical
database and can store almost any kind
of data for almost any purpose so
service names in this case will take the
form of service transport dot local this
is how we're mapping from a service name
to what you traditionally think of as a
domain name so in this case we're using
my app TCP my app is the service name
and TCP is the network transport that
we're using clients can then go and
query on this name to retrieve the
listing of devices supporting it once a
desired device is selected the IP
address port number and any other
necessary metadata are requested via DNS
service or SRV records since we're using
multicast DNS rather than the usual
internet DNS infrastructure there's no
need to go and register these domains
with any registrar or pay money you can
just simply broadcast them to network
peers as they're needed now that said
it's still a good idea to register your
service name with the ia na to prevent
any name collisions there's a free
service on ia na org that'll let you do
this now that we've gone over the
protocol details let's talk about using
the SSD API is on Android to broadcast
your apps custom service the good news
is you don't need to worry about most to
the protocol details since the OS takes
care of almost everything for you so
before you start let's say that we have
our app listening on an available port
this is just the code that you typically
used to open up a socket on Android but
notice that we're not explicitly
selecting a port here be careful to
never hard code your port number
are using NSD since other apps could be
using the same port number as your app
instead we'll ask the server the system
to give us a random unused port this is
okay though because we're going to go in
advertises to other devices so they'll
be able to discover which port you're
listening on so now that we have a
service listening for traffic on our
device we'll want to register that on
the local network the first thing to do
is to create an NST service info object
this object provides all the information
that other devices on the network will
use when they're deciding whether or not
to connect your device or not the
service type again uniquely identifies
the service your phone as advertising so
something like app named TCP and you'll
typically put an underscore in front of
each section as a matter of convention
the service name uniquely identifies a
particular instance of your app so this
is not the service type the service name
now with the service name it's usually a
good idea to use the device's Bluetooth
name just as something that's nice and
human friendly it should be unique but
if not it's not a big deal Android will
go in a pendant number to the end of the
name to correct that error finally we'll
set the port number that we selected
above so that other apps know which one
which port we selected calling register
service finally will inform the OS about
the new service and Android will take
care of broadcasting that information
after other devices as needed let the
end here there's a registration listener
which is a set of callbacks like on
service registered that'll let us know
about the success or failure of the top
eration we're going to see this pattern
a lot over the next few slides the
important thing to notice here is on
service registered which is where our
app can go and store the service name
even though we set this one registering
the OS might have changed it to resolve
a conflict from one other device on the
network remember I said that the service
name always has to be unique so this is
your chance to go and discover if it
wasn't and update your UI if needed you
might want to go and show the service
name to the user not all apps do though
so this might or might not be of
interest to you
now that our app is registered let's
take a look at how to issue a query to
find other devices service discovery
like service registration has two steps
setting up a discovery listener with the
relevant callback
and making a single asynchronous API
call to discover services let's work
backwards we'll start with the call to
discover services here you'll pass in
the service name that you're interested
in so again something like my app TCP
the name of the discovery protocol to
use which is always DNS SD again this is
not the protocol of your app it's the
service discovery protocol and right now
Android only supports DNS SD so this
argument will always be protocol dns SD
and finally a discovery listener object
which is what we'll use to get the
results of this discovery process the
listener will get a callback for each
device found and of course this
callbacks where your app can handle any
errors found the important method here
is on service found which is we're going
to find about all the services and
devices that were potentially interested
in and store them in the list this is
the list that you'll typically present
to the user and that will let them pick
which devices that they want to connect
to so once we know which devices we want
to connect to we call resolve service
this is another asynchronous call it's a
little bit expensive so again we have a
listener that's gonna go and get the
results of this and this is where we
find out the IP address and port number
of the device that we want to connect to
once you get that information then we're
just go ahead and connect to it directly
using a standard socket now before you
go off and play your game there's one
last thing you want to do when your
application exits it's very important to
unregister your service so that the OS
will stop advertising it to other
devices to do this call NSD managers
unregister service method whenever your
applications on the store you're on
pause method gets called you'll also
want to make sure to call stop service
discovery since the discovery process is
also a bit expensive and we don't want
to leave that running unchecked and
that's it you're all set to use network
service discovery to find out the copies
of your app on the network happy
networking